for a guy who hates every superhero
peacemaker show is full of references to
them for marquis heroes like batman and
superman to the obscure kite man and
batmite and even a little nod to the
upcoming black adam movie these are all
the easter eggs you missed in peacemaker
considering how daddy appeared to be at
the end of the movie it's a bit of a
miracle that peacemaker walked away from
the events of the suicide squad at all
but walk away he did and it turns out he
kept a few souvenirs from his ill-fated
trip to south america
after emptying the personal items he's
carrying during his hospital visit in
the first episode viewers can plainly
see a postcard from corto maltese
furthermore once peacemaker attempts to
pay his taxi driver for the car ride to
his dumpy trailer he offers him some
currency from corto maltese hinting to
the driver that it could be worth a
million dollars of course the driver
isn't the fool and takes his helmet to
his payment instead aside from being the
setting of the suicide squad film
quarter maltese has an extensive history
as a fictional country in the dc
universe it was first introduced in
frank miller's the dark knight returns
comics released in 1986. miller used
corto maltese as a sensitive pressure
point in the burgeoning tensions between
the us and the soviet union in the
ongoing cold war in that series the
soviets maintained control of the tiny
south american island but the u.s
supports a rebellion to usurp power over
the country's leadership this causes
russia to fire a nuclear warhead at the
u.s which superman attempts to stop
corto maltese is also referenced in tim
burton's batman in 1989 and countless
comic story lines it also makes several
appearances in the cw sprawling
arrowverse
in the first episode of peacemaker
viewers who took a quick pause to view
all the peacemaker's personal items at
the hospital may have noticed a note
with the name valentina on it along with
what might be a phone number dc comics
fans will likely make the connection to
valentina vostik a dc character who was
once a member of the doom patrol under
the alias negative woman the us
government uses her for her unique
espionage capabilities and she often
crosses paths with peacemaker where
peacemaker obtains her phone number in
his tv show is a bit of a mystery
perhaps it occurs off screen during the
club scene in the suicide squad or maybe
it's something he's been carrying with
him for quite some time seeing as
valentina is a russian defector to the
united states however she may have
interest in corto maltese or she could
simply be an associate of amanda waller
it's anybody's guess but perhaps we'll
see her in peacemaker season 2.
peacemaker has a bone to pick with the
justice league he may even be envious of
their popularity and prestige in the
superhero community after all peacemaker
often laments that no one likes him but
everyone loves superman in the first
episode peacemaker is made fun of by the
hospital janitor jamil when he claims to
be a superhero after jamil brings up his
favorite hero aquaman peacemaker offers
a story he heard from a credible source
awkward
yeah
i don't believe it
guy on twitter works for the aquarium
said for 50 bucks he brings him in the
back so he can have his way with a
sturgeon during the meeting clemson mirn
discusses how the butterfly aliens take
over human bodies by entering through an
orifice when the team jokes about jon's
slide depicting a butterfly entering a
human anus peacemaker mocks another
famous alien superman for apparently
having a unique fondness for bodily
waste
once again the internet apparently tells
no lies in peacemaker's mind later
peacemaker calls batman a jackass who
fails to do the job of eliminating
villains while arguing with his father's
neighbor after appearing as a guest
speaker at a school as a favor to jamil
and his daughter one child asked
peacemaker if he ever met the flash he
claims he has and that the flash is a
jerk although he uses more colorful
descriptors peacemaker also insinuates
that wonder woman has a hots for him
overall it's pretty clear that
peacemaker has very little respect for
the greatest heroes in the dceu
it's no secret that peacemaker doesn't
play nicely with others he also carries
grudges and seemingly has one against
the powerful dc comics villain eclipso a
powerful enemy who can absorb other
heroes and take control of their
abilities in the first episode an image
of the villain can be seen on
peacemaker's dartboard in his trailer
the peacemaker has a not so friendly
run-in with the villain in the 1992
comic series eclipso by robert laurent
fleming and odwin jermaine newman in
this series amanda waller led a group of
obscure dc characters known as the
shadow fighters peacemaker is a part of
the team tasked with bringing down
eclipso the clash ends in disaster as
many of the characters are killed
including peacemaker who dies in a
helicopter crash while this bit of
history can't possibly exist in the tv
series as peacemaker is alive and well
james gunn confirmed the reference on
twitter regardless peacemaker seems
keenly and begrudgingly aware of
eclipsa's existence
in the first episode of peacemaker
amanda waller tasked her daughter lyota
with the job of planting a fake
peacemaker diary in his apartment
that way once the inevitable result of
the mission is complete the search of
peacemaker's home will incriminate the
hapless mercenary and likely send him
right back into amanda waller's arms
the diary cover has a sticker featuring
a logo from the wayne foundation the
wayne foundation is a philanthropic
entity and bruce wayne's means of
advancing justice outside the cowl he
often uses the organization as a soapbox
to advocate for economic reforms that
will aid the lower class and help
support the citizens of gotham the wayne
foundation has also provided much needed
resources to the impoverished the
sticker on the faux peacemaker diary is
curious as the symbol actually resembles
the wayne enterprises logo seen in the
christopher nolan trilogy of batman
films not the different logo found in
the dc eu
of all the characters to receive a live
action reference batmite was perhaps the
least unexpected the 5th dimensional imp
is known in the dc comics lore as an
extreme batman fanatic essentially he's
like many of us just smaller and with
magical abilities he shares the same
home dimension as mr mixies pitselk a dc
villain who appears in a memorable
episode of superman the animated series
among other places however batmite often
just wants to see the dark knight in
action sometimes he even throws
obstacles in the hero's way just to gawk
at batman's prowess he's sometimes
helpful but is more often a pain in the
rear when john economist is bandaging up
peacemaker in episode 2 the two share
words as peacemaker insists on mocking
the tech liaison john loudly exclaims
that he'd rather work with harley quinn
the weasel or even batmite than with
peacemaker confused peacemaker questions
who batmind is either peacemaker is
living under a rock in the dceu world or
jon simply knows of batmite from his
experience in black ops missions under
amanda waller
in the second episode of peacemaker jon
frames peacemaker's father auggie smith
for the murder of the butterfly
bewitched assailant peacemaker was
forced to kill in the first episode when
detective sophie song sees augie's
followers kneeling before him in lockup
she remarks to her partner that she had
thought that capes were sent over to
arkham or bel reeve this aside indicates
that super villains typically receive
mental health treatment with their
prison stay or they're thrown to amanda
waller to be utilized in her suicide
squad arkham asylum is a famous and
iconic locale in the dc universe it's
located in gotham city and houses many
of batman's villains deemed insane or
mentally unstable of course villains
commonly escape from the maximum
security facility because well batman
needs something to do
belle reeve is another high security
facility that contains the most hardened
and powerful meta-humans amanda waller
is often seen operating the suicide
squad out of this prison most of the
suicide squad volunteers vying for a
reduced prison sentence come from this
prison detective song's mentioned at
both facilities acknowledges that the
world contains baddies that aren't fit
for ordinary prison life perhaps
considering that augie isn't just a
garden-variety scumbag and he's also the
white dragon he should have landed in
one of those places for his prison stay
instead
the system's overcrowded
he'll have to stay here through his
trial james gunn clearly has an affinity
for the lesser known and obscure odd
characters of the dc comics world in
episode 3 peacemaker mentions another
strange dc character known as doll man
hey doll man you ever meet him dumb man
he turns small mirn's explanation is a
bit of an oversimplification dull man
certainly does shrink but when he does
so he retains his physical strength as
if he were still full-grown while there
are multiple versions of the character
the most famous iterations were daryl
dane a scientist and lester colt a
special forces operator they both gained
the ability to shrink although lester's
was a bit more permanent at least for a
time who knows what iteration of the
character peacemaker may have been
referring to
peacemaker has lived a wild life the
series makes no secret of that as he
constantly unveils eyebrow-raising
tidbits about his past when talking to
mirn about the idea of allowing
vigilante to join the team in episode
four peacemaker questions the call
thinking that vigilante might be a
little too crazy for the mission at hand
mirin is aware of vigilante's issues but
is willing to ignore them because he
needs help peacemaker then makes a truly
surprising reference ever since i had a
team up with matt riedel i had my sense
of what's normal
matter eater lad hails from the distant
future by nature of his race he can eat
matter in all of its forms just as his
name implies most famously he joins the
legion of superheroes at first blush the
capability of eating anything might not
seem practical when employed for
superheroics however matter eater lad is
capable of using his powers to
neutralize devastating weaponry and he's
capable of eating powerful artifacts
that are deemed as indestructible
humorously peacemaker remarks that he
once saw the character eat an entire
wendy's restaurant his name is maddie
you know that yeah with all that's going
on why are you switching to him
not the time to be getting distracted
mern
in episode 4 augie's elderly neighbor
has fun taunting peacemaker whom he
believes is nothing more than a fake
superhero at one point peacemaker is
leaving his father's home with a bunch
of helmets and equipment the feisty
neighbor mentions that batman has a
coterie of super villains listing joker
riddler and mad hatter he then asks why
peacemaker doesn't have his own
collection of villains peacemaker
exclaims that his enemies are lying six
feet underground and he attacks batman's
legacy for not being capable of pulling
the trigger on these dangerous
characters batman doesn't kill people
because he's a he's a dark creature of
the night he's a jackass
of course everyone is familiar with
batman's famous rogues gallery joker
likely sits at the top of such a gallery
in most people's eyes however the
mention of mad hatter also known as
jurvis tech is yet another fun reference
to a villain that may not be widely
known this villain is famous for
developing a technology that allows him
to control others minds when he places a
card or hat on their head
in the fourth episode a fun little
superhero bunny figure can be seen
sitting on the dash of vigilante's car
this isn't simply a throwaway detail
included showing how childlike or
off-the-wall adrian is in fact it's a
reference to a fictional character ultra
bunny who was created for the dc eu by
james gunn as he revealed when he posted
a sketch of the character on instagram
in the suicide squad rick flack's team
is eliminated and he is taken captive by
guerrilla fighters rebelling against the
corto matijian regime however he's given
a new shirt and some gear when it
becomes clear that they are on the same
side the shirt he wears for the
remainder of the film is an ultra bunny
t-shirt apparently the fictional
character is even popular in corto
maltese
like peacemaker the starring role of the
dceu film black adam is played by a
former pro wrestler dwayne johnson it
only makes sense that serious fans get a
few teases during the wait for that
movie the peacemaker series provides one
minor but clear-cut reference to black
adam in episode 4 leota prods adrian to
kill peacemaker's father augie while
he's imprisoned adrian decides to get
close to the racist scoundrel the only
way he knows how by getting arrested
when adrian goes to a break area for
guards on duty to chuck a garbage can
into a window he passes a prison guard
who's killing time by reading the
newspaper one of the stories referenced
is that of an inner gang potentially
seizing control in the nation of kondok
in one version of his origin story black
adam was born thousands of years ago in
kondok a fictional country not unlike
egypt from a cultural standpoint the
wizard shazam granted him powers to act
as a protector however when a villain
kills his family black adam is enraged
and vows to protect kondok by any means
necessary including exacting bloody
vengeance on criminals the wizard sealed
black adam away to keep him from causing
further destruction
kite man isn't a stranger to recent dc
media projects as he had a humorous role
in the animated harley quinn series
vying for poison ivy's love as such this
reference may not be entirely lost on
everyone but even if you've never heard
of kite man you can probably figure out
what his power is it's just as
ridiculous as his name implies
kite man's entire superhero persona is
modeled around a kite he can fly or
glide like a kite and often employs
kite-related weaponry as a comic book
character he isn't well known and is
generally regarded as a charming relic
from a campier age of comic book
storytelling that said peacemaker at
least takes kite man seriously in
episode 5 peacemaker proudly displays
the newspaper clipping in his trailer
where he's hailed as a hero for
apprehending kite man while peacemaker
has been derided during the series as
being a wannabe superhero and even
sometimes a villain this clipping makes
it appear that he was once recognized as
a true blue good guy perhaps that's why
he keeps a reminder of this fond memory
in his trailer in the next episode he's
seen telling school children the story
of when he brought down kite man and
turned him in clearly his battle with
this less than nefarious villain is
something that gives him great pride
wouldn't he have crashed anyway due to
gravity
no
perhaps augie's elderly neighbor was
onto something peacemaker may kill his
enemies now but at one point he used to
operate as a straight arrow similar to
batman a hero he seemingly despises
midway through the series clemson mirn
makes a deal with a former comrade
casper lock to help tamp down calls for
reworking the evidence incriminating
peacemaker and lock poses as the new
police captain to accomplish this
however during locke's initial meeting
with mirn in episode 5 he references the
duo's past in the jungles of niacer
niacer is another fictional country in
dc lore located in northern africa it's
only been referenced during one story in
which superman travels to the country to
investigate a metahuman among the
membership of a church being suppressed
by the government when the military
takes part in killing missionaries the
metahuman known as redemption launches a
retaliatory attack superman comes to
blows with the character and redemption
proves to be able to handle himself
against the man of steel he can unleash
blasts of energy and maintain the same
level of strength as superman this could
just be a simple reference for fans to
consume or a potential narrative thread
that may bear fruits in the future only
time will tell
if the justice league exists in the dc
eu surely some of the other more famous
dc heroes like the green arrow do as
well in episode 8 the team sets off on
their noble mission to kill a cow which
is the food source of the series is
butterflies while devising a plan
peacemaker's anti-gravity helmet floats
away when the ota accidentally activates
it with a voice command though
frustrated peacemaker begins coming up
with a new plan coming up with the idea
to plant his sonic boom helmet on top of
the barn he mentioned shooting the
fishing line to the barn from the top of
one of the trees and letting the helmet
slide down the idea ends up reminding
vigilante of someone else like green
arrow no not like green arrow peacemaker
of course has just as much disdain for
green arrow as he does for every other
dc superhero even claims that green
arrow goes to brony conventions and
cosplays as the rear end of twilight
sparkle lyoto finally says what we're
all thinking by observing that
peacemaker has an absurd story for every
superhero either peacemaker is pretty
naive and genuinely believes everything
he reads on the internet or he simply
hates superheroes too much to care about
spreading false rumors honestly it's
probably both where do you get this
nonsense
google well it's not true you know more
than google well congratulations
all right this is likely one easter egg
nobody missed at the tail end of the
series the justice league does arrive at
the site of the butterflies clash with
peacemaker and crew but they're too late
while wonder woman and superman are
presented as conspicuous silhouettes
jason mamoa and ezra miller show up in
the flesh to reprise the roles of
aquaman in the flash aquaman even
hilariously drops an f-bomb as he
dismisses the rumors peacemaker's been
spreading about what he does with the
fish
i'm so
sick of that rumor
[Music]
it's
not a rumor
while it's obvious that henry cavill and
gal gadot did not show up for this
particular shoot day batman is curiously
absent from the lineup as well we know
that ben affleck is coming back as
batman for a final performance as a
character in the flash movie which
raises questions about why he didn't
show up here perhaps batman couldn't
arrive on the scene as fast as everyone
else this time regardless peacemaker
once again displays his disgust for the
team and doesn't even give them the time
of day the only people happy to see the
justice league in the show are
apparently the folks at home
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]